على بعد حوالي ساعة جنوب بيروت ، كانت
الأعلام الصفراء للعدو اللدود لإسرائيل ،
المتشدد اللبناني وجماعة
حزب الله السياسية ، هي أول علامة على أن
الدولة اليهودية ليس لديها الكثير من الأصدقاء
هنا
بعد أن جاءت مداهمة الشرطة للمسجد الأقصى
في القدس.  على
شكل ما يقرب من ثلاثين صاروخًا تم إطلاقها
عبر الحدود من جنوب لبنان
حيث كانت مخيمات اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
تؤوي عشرات الآلاف من النازحين على مدى عقود ،
ردت إسرائيل يوم الجمعة باستهداف
الأسلحة والجماعات الفلسطينية المسلحة
التي يقولون إنها أطلقتهم ،
فهذه قناة ري تمر
عبرها.  حقل الموز هذا
كان جسرًا فوقه يؤدي إلى
فندق على البحر ، ومن الواضح أنه تعرض لضربة
مباشرة ويقول السكان المحليون إن القوة كانت
شديدة لدرجة أنها هزت منازلهم ، كما
أصروا أيضًا على أن هذا لم
يكن مكانًا جيدًا  لتخزين الأسلحة في
أعقاب ذلك ، جذبت حشدًا من
السكان المحليين وأيادي المزارع ومن بينهم
خليل الرحي الذي لا يقدم أي اعتذار عن
إطلاق الصواريخ على إسرائيل
[موسيقى]
هل تريد السلام مع إسرائيل ،
فسألته بالطبع ألا يقول
فقط في الأسفل  على الرغم من أنها
قصة مختلفة كثيرًا ،
يُظهر لنا عبد الخالد عبد الساتير ، لاجئ سوري ، الشظية التي جمعها
من الانفجار الذي خلف حفرة في
سقف مزرعته حيث كان أطفاله
ينامون هنا في الوقت الذي
كان يسير فيه عبر أورانج غروف.
المزيد والمزيد من الأرض المضطربة
المنزل الذي أصيب بشظية على بعد
حوالي 200 ياردة من هنا يبدو
بعيدًا حتى ترى حجم الحفرة
يقول عبد السنتر لم يكن هناك أسلحة
هنا بشكل لا يصدق.
بصرف النظر عن الجذع ،
لم يعلن حزب الله مسؤوليته
عن أي صاروخ تم إطلاقه من
لبنان ولم تعلن أي
جماعة فلسطينية مسلحة. وتعهد الجيش اللبناني
بوقف الهجمات وتم تفكيك
عدة قاذفات صواريخ مفككة
وصواريخ مخبأة بين سفوح التلال
والبساتين الإرهابية يوم السبت.
وجدت واحدة أخرى على الرغم من عدم وجود علامة على
وجود هجوم جديد في الطريق على الأقل في الوقت الحالي